joining us right now to discuss the oj
parole hearing that's going to go down
at about a half an hour time expected in
the state of nevada is Sports
Illustrated legal analysts and also from
si.com michael mccann how are you
Michael I'm doing well rich in yourself
I'm okay
so let's let's talk about OJ here what
what is going to go down in about twenty
nine minutes time well it probably will
be a good day for OJ rich and I say that
because he'll have a hearing and under
Nevada law these hearings are pretty
preordained in terms of what's going to
happen Nevada uses eleven factors most
of them are pretty objective that assess
whether or not a person up for parole is
likely to commit crime again in the
future
among other things and under these
eleven factors he does very well so a
lot of people are thinking well what
about the elephant in the room what
about the belief that he committed
murder but that's just irrelevant from
this hearing or at least it should be so
the hearing should go probably in a way
that it's not that dramatic although I
think anything that OJ says or does has
a certain level of drama so how does it
how does it work then I mean how could
this go sideways it could go sideways if
he said if there's things we don't know
for instance has there have there been
any disciplinary write-ups we've heard
rumors that he's had some minor issues
but as far as the public knows there
have been no disciplinary write-ups
that's one thing and secondly if he says
something that suggests he isn't
contrite though he didn't act that way
back in 2013 when he had his first
parole hearing at he actually was was
pretty differential and apologetic I
assume he's going to take the same
approach today but if he somehow lashes
out I don't think it's going to happen
in look he's an actor right so he's
someone that knows how to play a role
but it could go sideways of something
like that happens okay so again and I
got 27 minutes I guess and the rest of
us until this all goes down how is it
going to work he sits there and do you
know the actual mechanics of what day is
so assuming it goes as normal they'll
run through the 11 factors they'll say
mr. Simpson the age of first arrest you
were in your
40s that's actually good for him under
the system because the older you are
when you're first arrested it suggests
that it's less likely you're going to
get in trouble again in the future the
fact that he's male is a negative under
Nevada law because males are more likely
at least the theory goes to commit
crimes so they're going to run through
the 11 factors and it will have to
answer some of their questions in
relationship to those factors but it's
just they're going to basically run
through a list and have a discussion and
it may only take 20 minutes as last
hearing in 2013 took 20 minutes this
time will be a little different because
they'll likely take a break talk about
it and then come back and if there's a
unanimous decision essentially he'll be
granted parole that will become
effective October 1st okay that was my
question for you Michael McCann of
Sports Illustrated so we are we are
going to get a yay or nay today we we
will though there so that we make it
quickly and in that case that would mean
two for commissioners vote unanimously
if there's dissension depending upon how
many dissenting votes we might get an a
quickly if there's something like a
three to one vote in favor they then
have to contact two other commissioners
and see if they can get to four so that
whether that happens today or another
time or the belief is that it would
happen today but that's all that
presents a little bit of a question mark
so if he's not paroled what happens next
if he's not paroled his eligibility to
remain in prison would continue and he
would likely serve until October 30th of
2022 and he'll be 75 years old because
he served nine years of a 33 year
sentence based on what happened in that
Las Vegas hotel room over the stuff that
he was accusing folks who who were
trying to make money off of it had taken
right that's what I'm sorry about it
it's a raid of memorabilia and it was
all caught on video and it's just really
a terribly planned foolish really and he
was caught as as often happens if you
try to raid a hotel room and he received
a very harsh punishment then he would
say that punishment may have been
somewhat of a makeup call for
or what happened in the 90s I don't know
it was within the grounds of the judges
discretion but he did have a parole
hearing and a few years ago and the
sentence was essentially reduced because
of that so he would be able to get out
in 2022 but yeah look this this isn't
going away for him even if he's paroled
on October 1st he will be a parolee
he'll be subject to the terms of that
Fred Goldman's going to keep going after
him he's never ever going to be free
well in that regard Michael I wanted
that that leads me to some other line of
questioning here is that let's say he
does get out and you know Ronald Goldman
and the Goldman family have a won a long
time ago how much money are they
supposed to get from OJ Simpson's Bloods
it's thirty three three and a half
million goes to the brown and Goldman
family so and he claims he's broke what
about his NFL pension what do you know
about that and whether whether the
Goldman and Brown family can go after
that one so jackets up that should be
off-limits rich because under erisa a
federal law that protects pensions it
qualifies as a protected pension plan so
that money which has been reported to be
as much as $25,000 a month should likely
remain out of the reach of the Goldman
and brown families okay so what does
happen if do you know I guess I could
ask Carl Douglas this one when he joins
us and he's one of the people who said
that the conviction that he's trying to
get paroled from today was in fact a
thrown on him because of what happened
in the 90s but what do you think happens
with OJ if he is paroled where he goes
and what happens I think well if he is
paroled he's going to have to get
permission to leave the state because as
a parolee he'll be subject to all sorts
of restrictions on his travel on where
he lives and it'll have to work that out
with his supervising officer but
assuming that is worked out I would
imagine he might go back to Florida
which is where he was residing before
Florida has changed his law as far as I
understand it on its Homestead Act
basically if you buy a house it's hard
to civilly forfeit it but
as I understand it Florida has modified
its law so he may not get the protection
he wants from the Goldman family if he
buys a house there
but I don't know what his earning power
is I mean he's 70 years old I assume and
this is a big assumption that he'll try
to capitalize off of his fame I assume
he'll do paid interviews rather than non
paid ones there are all sorts of
variables there but but after him the
whole time I think will be Fred Goldman
who's 76 years old but he's a youthful
76 I think he will file petition after
petition in court trying to get any
money that OJ gets but the hard part of
the civil lawsuit is it's basically as
he has said it's a piece of paper you
got to go and force it and it seems like
Fred Goldman's going to keep fighting it
so last one for you Michael McCann if he
is paroled today if AJ is paroled today
he's got it and he he's got to stay in
love lock until October first so he has
at least a couple of more months left in
prison and if that happens what what is
there something that could happen
between now and then that prevents him
from getting out on it's possible rich
me there's a disciplinary matter parole
is a discretionary function it's not a
right it's something that that it's sort
of like they're giving you a break but
they can take it back because you're
serving out your sentence under parole
the sentence continues and if he does
something wrong that but I play devil's
advocate to that he apparently has been
a model prisoner as far as we know for
the most part and I think it's unlikely
something would happen in the next two
months but you never know Michael I
appreciate it
always and we'll chat down the line
because you know things always crop up
in the coastal sports law and then
regular law with sports folks I
appreciate the time thanks for having me
on you got it as Michael McCann at
McCann sports law so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show lap
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show